so in the past i've told stories about
how broken our health care system is
through personal experiences i've had
with the health care system of course
many of you remember the
appendectomy incident which i described
in the youtube video titled
my twenty seven thousand four hundred
ninety five dollar appendicitis that was
a doozy
back in late 2019 there was also what we
now know of as the podiatry debacle
that was earlier 2019 you can hear about
that
in the youtube video titled my 829
dollar
10 minute long doctor's visit i have a
new one for you today this one comes to
us from the world of
otto rhinolaryngology as many of us
know it uh ear nose and throat medicine
now i'm not telling you this so that you
as a european viewer can write to me and
say
david this would have cost me zero out
of pocket in my country or
david this would have been 20 bucks in
my country i know that
i know that please don't email me about
it okay it's a look into our health care
system i know how well yours is working
i don't need you to tell me david that
would have been free out of pocket for
me
so i as a self-employed person
get my own health insurance through what
are called
the exchanges and for years i've had
what is called a
silver level plan now the gist of how
this works is you know bronze
silver gold platinum the higher you go
the more you pay each month but in
theory the less you pay for services
as you use them in terms of co-pays
and deductibles so like a bronze lever
level plan
would be cheaper monthly than my silver
plan
but it would typically have a higher
deductible and a higher co-pay
that needs to be uh met the higher
deductible that needs to
be met before the insurance will cover
anything silver plans cost
more but they cover more gold and
platinum you might end up paying a
thousand dollars a month for a single
person
but you might have really really cheap
or no co-pays okay
fine i've had a silver level plan for
years
and my premiums have dramatically
increased as have my co-pays so
for the same plan over the years
in 2018 i was paying 439 a month
and my specialist co-pay was 40
in 2019 it went up to 454 a month
and my co-pay went up to 50 in 2020
i was up to 478 a month and my co-pay
was up to 70 dollars and this year
i am paying five hundred and twenty
dollars a month
and my co-pays are up to seventy five
dollars so right now
i pay 520 a month that's 62.40 for the
year
just for the coverage that's if i use
nothing i guess i get an annual physical
for that
right now uh i am paying that if i don't
avail myself of
any services but i'm aware
that for lab work like blood draws
mris cat scans i have a two thousand
dollar deductible to me
i have to pay the first two grand for
that
type of uh labs and mris and that type
of thing
before my insurance will cover anything
so i've been having some ear pain
my dentist thought it was caused by
clenching my jaw at night might be a tmj
type of thing
but it's been going on for a while so
eventually my doctor said
go see an ent to rule out other things
so i'm thinking great
i pay 520 a month for insurance i know
my specialist
co-pay is 75 i make an appointment
i get a referral i confirm this doctor
is in my network
i'm good to go with my 75 dollars
i go last week doctor looks says
things look good let's do what's called
i just want to look uh
in your throat let's do a laryngoscopy
meaning they put a camera into my throat
through the nose i don't recommend it
it's not
fun but okay it was medically what my my
doctor wanted to do
let's do an audiometry up to test
your hearing and make sure you don't
have like a eustachian tube issue
i say sure now this is all stuff that
was done
in the office so when she suggests it i
say yeah let's do it i'm here
let's let's do what you want to do so
everything looks fine it's probably
tmj from clenching at night i've got a
diagnosis fantastic i pay my 75
and i go home i now get a bill
saying that this was a thousand thirty
three dollar visit
and i'm going to owe almost another 500
and i say wait wait a second how can
this be
i paid my 520 for my insurance
the doctor is in network i had a
referral i paid my co-pay i don't have a
deductible for specialists
how do i owe another 500 well i look
closely at the bill
and it says that's right david the
office visit
was billed at 420 typical for
specialists you paid your 75.
my insurance good for them negotiated a
discount so they add another 92
and the office visit is paid but then
here we go that camera in my throat for
30 seconds
that's another 400 david the audiometry
that's another 140 the tympanometry
which is five seconds to
check the pressure in my ears that's
another fifty dollars and
lo and behold that's billed like a blood
test
that's billed like an mri so even though
i'm in a room with the doctor and she
looks in my ears with one tool
and looks in my nose with another and
then puts in a camera
the camera is a completely different
type of thing
that is like lab work or an mri or blood
work
and i need to meet my 2 000 a year
deductible which of course i haven't met
because it's march
now thankfully my insurance did me the
favor of negotiating better rates so
even though the camera normally costs
400
they've negotiated it down to 280 for me
um
the hearing tests they've negotiated
down to 110. so bottom line
in addition to my 75 copay
and paying 520 for a month of health
insurance i owe an additional 466.
in essence if i didn't have any
insurance
i could have said do you offer a cash
discount
i might have paid a little more for some
of these items
i probably can't negotiate as good a
rate as my insurance company can
but i would have avoided paying the 520
a month in premiums all along so
needless to say
i'm thinking about maybe i switched to
something called direct primary care
um and then a high deductible plan and
kind of self-insure
for the higher deductible it it's a mess
if you're in europe
don't email me i know this would have
cost you nothing out of pocket
you don't need to make me feel any worse
but that's another bit of insight
into the american health care system
if you are anything like me you probably
aren't thrilled with the idea of going
into
a doctor's office right now and
thankfully there is a
practical and affordable way to take
control of your health
and get personalized care from the
comfort of your home
it's a service called steady md they're
one of our sponsors
you take a quiz you get matched with a
licensed
primary care physician who understands
your health needs you have a one hour
video call with your new doctor you
establish a meaningful relationship with
them and after that
your doctor is available to you anytime
by text phone or video chat this is not
a random doctor on call
each doctor at steady md has a limited
number of patients so they actually have
time
to listen to you you get the personal
attention that you deserve
they can do almost everything an
in-person doctor
can do perform medical evaluations talk
to you about health concerns
send prescriptions to your home or local
pharmacy
and anything they can't do online
they'll quickly set you up with
an in-person provider to do things like
blood tests as an example
you don't need insurance it's only 99
bucks a month with
no other fees or co-pays there are so
many
practical advantages to using steady md
for primary care
and it's also so much more affordable
go to steadymd.com pacman to take the
free quiz see which doctor is right for
you i took their quiz they matched me
with a doctor
who specializes in my particular health
needs and situation the doctor they gave
me
is a really perfect fit for me and my
medical needs there's no risk no
commitment to get started
just click the link right underneath
this video